good morning it's five o'clock it's
tuesday morning we start with breaking
news we sure do clark county fire
department fighting a two alarm fire
candace charles joining us live here
from the scene this is nellis and
cheyenne and candace you have an update
for us what's going on over there
yeah heather good morning to you good
morning folks the cloud cleaning fire
department says they got a caller around
three this morning from a passerby
saying that atv performance was on fire
when they got here they found one unit
fully engulfed the middle unit of this
automotive strip mall they pulled lines
they were able to get that fire out they
caught a second alarm shortly after 3 30
but they didn't need to use many of
those units they had about three trucks
on the scene and 12 engines and two
rescues of course north las vegas was
out here to help as well at this point
they do not know how the fire got
started arson is on the way to go ahead
and figure that out once we get more
details we'll let you know about that at
this point
from cheyenne and nellis on down the
northbound side is currently closed they
say it will be closed for about another
15 minutes so we're asking you to take
caution in the area again as we learn a
little bit more about what happened in
this fire we'll let you know but for now
i'm candice charles 8 news now